ついに来たで
年に一度
乙女たちが恥じらいながら
その意中の男性に愛を告白する
する超ビッグイベント バレンタインデー
今年も行産チョコレートもらおうか そんなことを言って去年はいくつもらったんだ
ん 去年は去年ですやん
ゼロだな。
ば、バカにしてー!
せやったら、去年あんたらいくつもらおうた言うね!
チャイ!
オン!
イ!
チートイ!
オラ確か、チョコレート7つだったかな。
オラ、めぐみ1点ガイダモノしてー。
テイ!
ロン!
サンアンコウドライチ初地獄待ちだ!
ギリギリ!
オレは、トモミとジュンコとリエとマサコと、
13個かな。
えぇ!そ、そんな!
ロン!コークシー!十三面町!
トヨトミ、お前はいくつなんだよ?
え?
ゼロ
さすがよ!
さすがワイの師匠や!
お互い今年こそ頑張りましょう!
ハッピーバレンタインデー!
あきらちゃん!
はい、トヨトミ君。私の手作りチョコ!
ありがとう!
師匠
みんなにはギリチョコね はい
すまねえな
サンキュー
はやみの相場感じる
甘いものなんざ女子どもの食べ物やが
くれる言うならものたのかい
あら
ごめん 数間違えちゃったみたい
影薄いんだもん
ええわい そんなもん
見とれ!今日中に彼女作って絶対にバレンタインチョコもろたる!
とちくしょう!ナンバーナンバーワンのナンパ師と呼ばれたこのワイの実力見せたるワイ!
お嬢さん!ちょこっとそこで茶でもしばかへんけ!
やよ!
お嬢さん!ちょこっと!
冗談じゃないわよ!
お嬢さん!チョコ!
うるさいわね!
あかーん
東京の女はみんな
お前の価値を分かっとらんのや
早速さ早速さ
そこの彼女をちょっと待った
逃さへんで
わいは中学の時
短距離でケッタイ書いてたんや
私だって
鎌倉高校のジョイナーと言われた女です
彼女、鎌倉出身かー!
なかなかやるやないか、彼女。
あら、あなただって。
わたら、うまくやっていけそうやな。
そうね。
ここがわいの師匠の家や。ま、遠慮せんと上がってええよ。
なんだ、いそうのか。
もう帰ってこないかと思ったのに。
あれ?どなた?
わいのつれですや
はじめまして、あさみです
これ、みなさんでどうぞ
お、よくできた女だ
おめえにはもったいねえだな
あの、お茶入れてもいいですか?
あ、いいわよ、私やるから
あさみちゃんはけんじんくんのわきにすわってて
ええです
師匠の彼女であるはやみはんに
そないなことさせられまっかいな
おう、熱いの入れたっていい
何が入れたって
そんなんで早したよ
ママは生きなんだよ!
というわけで、ワイが入れるわ。
あ、いいですよ。ケンジンさんは座っててください。
いや、ワイが。
いえ、あたしが。
ワイが。
あたしが。
ワイがやる予定ね!
あたしがやるんです!
アサミちゃん。
ケンジンさん。
おい!どっちでもいいから早くしてくれ!
はい、今すぐ!
ほな、にぬけでワイも入りまひょうか。
おう、入れ入れ。
俺たちもカモが1匹よりは2匹のほうがおいしいもんな。
カモ?
このワイが?
そりゃちゃんちゃらおかしいわ!
お茶がわきました!
で、できる?
ナイスコンビネーション。さすが恋人同士だべ。
彼女さえできた今の場合に、勝てる奴は少なくともこの中にはおら・・・
すまへん、ちょっとこの線から出たってくださいね。
今の場合に勝てる奴は少なくともこの部屋の中にはおらへん!
おいおい。
お酒、そろが。
帰り討ちだ。
あ,もう...
イカワイのうちましを見ときや。
パーワンかeピン、どっちを切るか。
ここは当然だま。
じゅんちゃん三色ドラ1のチーワン狙いで、
ハネマンに受けるよね。
よし!
去年チョコレートを7つもらった男の実力!
得と思い知らせてやるぜ。
リーチ!
そんなんでんだらリーチしとけよ!
そのドラポンや!
じゃあこっちでリーチだ!
やるぞ!
くっそだ!
サンソや!
家じゃ来ないなら、積もってみせよう!
ローン!
メンタンピン裏一!
おいおい、ドラさんやー!
いやぁぁぁぁぁ!ダムロー!
どや、ワイの実力?
ハサミマーじゃ、わかんない!
あら?
うわぁ、かわいい!なんですか?この花。
それはね、オゼウさん、ツカンポの花といって、
悲しいことがあると咲く私の心の代名詞なのです
きれい
積んでもいいですか?
どうぞどうぞ
どんどん咲くから好きにしていいよ
咲かしてたまるか
チーヤー
ポンヤー
パワー
ううううううううううううううううううず
困ったなぁ
アンタ、早く気になよ
時の刻みはアンタだけのものやない
何ぃぇ!そんなセリフこの場合が当たってから言いやがれぃ!
フッ、アンタ、背中がお花畑だぜ
論陳述
つくわあああああああ!
うわぁ、綺麗!
ケンさんにも飾ってあげる。
やめとけって!
どうして、こんなに綺麗なのに。
リーチ!
4枚目の3-1引いてもうた!
んー、E-1、数-1はドラ筋、しかもマチゴロや!
数をピン切ってサブローピン、
うー、パッソ、イー、数、ワンの受けの イー、シャン、テンにしたろうか?
それともパーソ切って、イス・リャン・ウー・ワン・リャン・ウー・サブ・ロー・ピンにすべきやろうか?
いや、スーピン・パッソ、どっちも危険や!ここは一発!
現物切って、ウー・パーソ・リャン・ウー・ワン・リャン・ウー・ピンに受けや!
あら!ドラつもってもうた!でもしゃあない!ウーは切りや!
あだーしもうたー!バスを頭にしてローチッソを落とせばよかったんやー!
おれ!
そうすりゃりゃんぴんで当たっとったー!
なに一人で力んでる?
もうあかんわー!
こいつは…
ローン!218、うらうらー!
あちゃー!師匠のつかんぽがうつってもうたー!
ロー バインマン
ロー おやっぱり
俺にもやらせろ
ツバ セランカ
ダブル スーパー ズガー
じゃあ 俺らもチョコもらいに行くから
ごちそうさ 彼女とお幸せに
スーパー
さて、私もそろそろ帰りまーす。楽しかった。
ま、待ってよ、アサミはん。
え?
ワイを、傷つき倒れるこのワイを、見捨ててゆく言いまんのか。
アサミはん、アサミはんはワイのことが、好きやったんやないんか!
あ、あ、あ、あ…
ええ、好きよ。だから…
だから?
いつまでも、いいお友達でいましょうね。
ああ、ああ、そ、その言葉は…
うふふふ、じゃあねー。
行くか。
とどめだったわね
いつまでもお友達でいましょうね
こうしてケンジンは死んだ
おやすみなさい
三色ドライチ!天敗だ!
やーん!おやまーん!
いっはー!今日はついてるなー!
なんや、師匠!
今日はめっちゃついてますやん!
あんまり調子に乗らないといいんだけど。
いらっしゃい!
どうなりまして、ママさん。
あれは三条院きみまろ。
え?
あの日本経済を牛耳っていると言われる三条院グループの御曹司
いらっしゃいませ!
席はありますか?
その御曹司が市政のジャンソーに来てまで親の七光かい?
豊臣くん!
面白い人だ
それじゃあ、その宅に入れてもらおうかな
大丈夫ですか、ママさん?
このボンボンが世間の波の荒さを教えてやるぜ
ではまずトン一曲
オヤマンからスタートしましょうか
山頂院さんは予告通りの定数の役を作るので有名なのよ
なにー
ベーブルースじゃあるまいし
それ
本
チッダブトンか
こっちも勝負手だぜ
早めにドラ切り
ドラポン
ジョーそんなん泣かさんといてーな
流れちまったもんガタガタ言うな
よしレイチ
さあ行くぞ
イチシャーホンツイペイコ
初を一発で積もってバイマンだ
この一発は誰にも止められねー
寒いー!
ロン!
ダブトンドラさん、一万二千だ。
ズガン!
何のまだまだ!
次もトイメンからゴッパをあがろうか?
師匠!
ロン!
親の六十歩三眼光、五千八百プラス一本歯。
ズガーン!
先輩!
乾杯!
ほんと久しぶりですね。こうやってお話できるの。
そう。僕がロンドンに留学してからだから、二年ぶりぐらいかな。
君は急にレディーになったね。
やだ、先輩ったら。
今日は、君に渡したいものがあるんだ。
こ、これは?
僕と君の再会の記念だよ。
こんな高価なもの。
あたし、受け取れません。
えぇ!?
ま、まさか好きな人がいるの?
はい。
ああ、今日はアキナちゃんに渡したものがあるんだ。これ!
きゃー!まさか給料の3ヶ月分ってやつ?
なにこれ?
何だ、アキナちゃんらしくもないな。玄武館だよ。
どしゃー!
僕は絶対諦めないよ。
えー、寒いやー。
寒い時は、こたつが一番ですやん。
あ、はい。
お前でろ。
何言うてばんねん。ここは師匠の部屋ですやろ。
師匠の客は、師匠が応対してくださいよ。
あのな!
もう、何やってんのよ。
あきなちゃん!
お前は!
これはこれは、また会ったね。
まさか君が豊臣くんだとはね。
君は本当に早見くんを愛しているのか?
僕は愛している!
な、なに?
僕はオックスポードを出て三条院グループに就職。
24歳にして年収は優に8000万強!
おまけに身長188センチで顔も良い!
だがしかし、ハヤミ君は僕より君を選ぼうとしている
え、アキラちゃんが?
師匠、ヘラヘラ笑ってる場合と違うでしょう
だけど僕はまだ君をハヤミ君の恋人と認めてはいない
なに?
そこでだ、君とも大石と麻雀で勝負しようじゃないか
君が僕に勝つことができたら僕は潔く身を引く
どうだ?
ハヤミは間違われ
人生ってもんは常にギャンブルや
何事も勝てば鼻 負けて落ちれば泥
そ そんな
確かに 僕が人と互角に渡り合えるのは マージャンくらいしかない
リーチ
ロン リーチ一発 チートイ ウラウラ
しかし そのマージャンもこんなに弱い
豊臣くん、まだ始まったばかりよ。頑張って。
かん。
一気にたんやをどらさんだ。
りゃんわんはどら、すうぴんはさんまいづかいか。しゃぼまちにしてもでにくいな。
すうぴんぎりのさぶろうきゅうぴんまちはふりてんときてる。
生きてる
よーし
振りてんだ
師匠、お助けします
こいつピンズのメンツができんと困っとるんやな
泣かせへんど、お前が今捨てたパーピンや
ちー
なんや、その泣きは
リーチ
つも、万眼
太い、月が僕より絶対太い
師匠、弱音入ったら飽きまへん
よーし、今度こそリーチだ
なんて諦めの悪い
えい、それ、どうだ
うん、苦労としてはる
やっぱりはやみはんは心の底じゃ師匠の味方
これがはやみはんの答えなんや
この愛されてまでなんで上がれへんねや師匠
こんなこと言ったってきっかけなんだもん
えいっ
論 面本しろ
ありがとうはやみくん 君の愛を感じるよ
くそ こうなったらわいが叩いたら
いくでー
ポン
酸素積もれ!
あかん。
ツモギリ!
師匠!
何食い流してまんのや!
でも、ええところを引いた。さすがワイヤ!
よーし、たてちんりゃんうっそきゅうそまちてんぱいや。
きゅうそ!
あかーん!師匠からは当たれへん!
よーし、ツモギリを強調しつつ!
ビーチや!
えい、これは取ったら?
師匠!どいつを落としやったんか!
力一発敗漫や!
はやめくん、一体こんな奴のどこがいいって言うんだい?
人は誰でも逆境の時があるわ。今の彼がそう。
でも先輩は、逆境に立たされたとき、こんな色鮮やかな素敵な花を咲かせることができますか?
な、なんだって?
うわー、高値燃費ニックー!
子供の頃からエースで四番の道を歩いてきた先輩は確かにすごいわ。
でも、子供の頃から補欠でベンチ
それでもくじけずに続けてる人はもっと立派よ
美しい
そうか、すっかり忘れていた
道端に咲いている花がこんなにもけなげで美しいものと
サンジョイン先輩
僕の負けだ
こんな美しいものを見せられてはねえ
だけど僕は決して諦めない
僕にもこんな花が咲かせられるようになったらきっと
きっと君を迎えに
あ、あ、あきらめようかな
ああ、それぞれの胸に宿る思いを知ってが知らずか
スカンポの花は何も言わず
ただ黙って咲いているのでありました
ジャンソーのメンバーって大変なんですって
お客さんの台打ちやったり
マナーのお手本になったり
豊臣くんに勤まってるのかしら
次回スーパーズガンようこそ一番館へ
麻雀ルール教えますきっと見てね眠っちゃいや
ご視聴ありがとうございました
エクセンスかもうぞ
やるでやるのまんまくどころ
飛んで早くな
さあ来いよ
ここは三面町どころ
行くなかみきゃ
徳島そこの国籍が派だ
相撲にも負けんくんにやりづいて
勝手飲み越すビールがうまい
スカット! オタカは命がけ!
スカット! スカット! アルカレッド! アルアルアイラ!
ご視聴ありがとうございました